right okay so we now turn to something
pretty cool an inspiring story of a
young man who found success in the
depths of failure he's been on a mission
to help others ever since trent shelton
was a college football star whose dream
of playing in the nfl fell apart that
sent him on a journey of self-discovery
now he's a popular motivational speaker
with tens of millions of followers on
social media it all starts with you
protect your peace and don't die with
your dreams are among his signature
phrases jamie wax spoke with the 37 year
old about his surprising path to wisdom
jamie good morning good morning nate a
truly inspirational person in addition
to being a social media star shelton is
also an author his second book the
greatest you is now out in paperback and
is highly recommended we talked to him
at his home outside of dallas where he
lives with his wife and three kids and
discovered why flaming out of the nfl
was the best thing that could have
happened to him
hey what's up rehabbers across the world
trent here the voice is direct
understand if you only matter to them
when they need something then let me
tell you this you don't matter to them
at all it is passionate don't you dare
give up and unfilter you can fool a lot
of people
you can fool social media you can fool
your friends
but you'll never fool yourself and when
trent shelton speaks he has one goal in
mind
to make sure that people have some type
of voice when they're going through
their silent battles to let them know
that
it's okay so tonight the question i ask
you shelton a motivational speaker has a
following of more than 50 million
dispensing bits of inspiration and
wisdom on social media he got here not
with a steady climb to the top
but with a plunge to rock bottom you
knew you were going to play on sundays
in the nfl absolutely
a gifted athlete from a young age
shelton would shine in college football
he thought was his destiny i just knew
like you know this is what i'm going to
do with my life i mean you end up a
superstar wide receiver at baylor yeah
and you are literally watching the draft
and all your dreams are tied into it and
over 250 names are called out and not
one of them
is trent shelton not at all that's the
first moment in my life where i felt
like i wasn't enough
shelton signed as a free agent in 2007
with the indianapolis colts but was cut
soon after it's a pattern he experienced
with two other teams until his fading
dream of playing in the nfl disappeared
completely i started to feel
less worthy about myself because we tie
our work to external things and so i
started to lose myself turn to things
that i probably shouldn't have turned to
just to
numb the pain and i got to a place where
i looked in the mirror and i was like i
only recognize this guy
shelton knew he had to make a change and
find a new purpose in life
that's when he came up with rehab time
hey what's up rehabs across the world
trent here rehab simply is this putting
a strength back into a weakness it all
starts
with you whatever that is right whether
it be physical mental spiritual
emotional the things that you need work
on it's the work that you do every
single day to go on that journey of
trying to find out you know what you're
here for
you find that higher purpose
life becomes a lot more beautiful if all
you had to offer was friendship
like who would still be around that
rehab journey eventually inspired him to
start making his videos it's time for
you to reprogram yourself in greatness a
way to connect to his true self to
embrace his imperfections and ultimately
connect with others on a similar journey
do you think we as a culture should be
better at teaching our children how to
fail and the importance of failure a
thousand percent success is not a
straight path right it's up and down we
got to change the definition of failure
failure is only when you quit
failure is really feedback and perhaps
the biggest lesson that success
sometimes disguises itself as a failure
do you think if you had
all the dreams that were in you
for the nfl
come true
that you would be reaching as many
people and as successfully as you are
now 100 guarantee i wouldn't but i tell
you right now i get more thrills more
more peace when
somebody says trent this message you
know helped save my life than i ever did
running out of tunnel with 50 60 000
people screaming your name it's rehab
time
let's get it
[Music]
whoa like him so inspirational right
this was a beautiful experience uh being
in his home with him and his wife it was
great every athlete hopes that they can
play in a game and 60 000 people rise to
their feet millions at home they follow
you and scream for you
and it's not ironic i think it was fate
that he didn't play in the nfl for a
long time and now he has millions of
people that are healing because of him
not cheering for him right not giving
you this very surface level reaction to
a play that you made this is deeper than
that so his mission on earth was bigger
than football i mean my favorite lyric
ever is a leonard cohen lyric that says
there's a crack in everything that's how
the light gets in yeah this story makes
me think of that being broken and
acknowledging it is one of the most
powerful things we can share especially
at this moment in history but isn't it
something when he didn't get to play
football and he said he turned to things
that he shouldn't have that's a down
moment for you and something bigger
comes out of that and when you're in it
you just don't think it's going to get
any better than this and now it's much
bigger than he ever dreamed i would
imagine absolutely nate you played with
him you know i played with him yeah he
was a young man trying to fight him in
the league yeah a man of faith very
passionate but i can tell that he didn't
know what was next um but it just so
happens the world opened up to him
that's right yeah i'm glad you found the
book and brought us his story you go
trent shelton well done trent you go
jamie waxes thanks guys yeah you go
jamie wax i'll take that i'll take that